a cair em balé balé por ai ai ai ai eu
falei que falar de línguas e sabe
futuras e eventuais a dizer que não
quero falar em nossa que a bola só da
língua portuguesa em geral estão lá só
português só portugal que é errado como
nos outros países que falam a língua a
resposta a esta pergunta é um pouco
diferente do habitual a atenção ele que
isto é da empresa total de 32 hoje para
explicar porque é que eu acho que posso
dar muito mais de proteção permanente e
nós dos outros o profissional dá
trabalho nesta área e um foguete mas aí
meus colegas pelos em quantas línguas de
todos os riscos em frases e da escola' o
cenário que nós os índios não são
palavras larvas mas sim e por isso a
frase como vai pressionar por sua vez o
time muita saudade me faz ser
encontrados sound traduzido em todos os
dias do rio a opção das músicas
claro que muitas vezes exigem mais
palavras às vezes já em mudar um pouco
fácil mas nós dois trenzinhos estas
palavras inclusivas todos os dias de
hoje nunca para ser um país como um
espaço em branco no placar mas conseguiu
a segunda é mais curiosa
nós podemos dizer que o coloca na
introdução de um centro
todas as linhas 11 e elas são muitas não
só está indo
domingos já foi uma encontradas pelo pai
está entendendo não teve início hoje em
dia vejo diferente mais ou menos tem um
som do visado nos próximos eventos entre
williams e não estou a falar de wheat
solta a língua e próprias palavras como
um todo
estamos sempre línguas no mundo todo
basta pensar num país com o campo
magnético e mais de 800 pensar nos
estados unidos aos cinemas uma só língua
as duas espanholas que está em muitas
línguas dos 100 mais hoje porque estava
na europa e os países de língua
[Música]
portuguesa e língua portuguesa
temos falado muito com um terno
o português é uma língua e por fim
[Música]
e havia mas tem uma das línguas
conhecidas da nossa própria constituição
é uma obrigação do estado fez o time
português e etoo anos e falo da língua
gestual portuguesa que é uma língua
própria esperado um dos trechos a língua
portuguesa não é entre os projetos
basta pensar que a nossa luta no brasil
para o próximo goleiro que está próximo
é uma rotina
no entanto no caso da língua portuguesa
além do mais próxima em língua gestual
da espécie no brasil 47 línguas
não existe nova produzir palavra
mesmo assim quando fala de coisas
o que é certo é que estevam para todos
falavam que não é só passar ao lado dos
dois exemplos procurados é muito simples
mas é café
como é que nós temos que aprender e
equipar um estrangeiro está com mais que
nós mas não é essa no entanto quando nós
nos lembramos a prova perfeita e as
pessoas em portugal de férias no brasil
é uma chapa única
a maior mostra do espaço onde vamos
tomar café e não acontece com a fifa mas
são iguais na boca de crianças por
exemplo palavra praia praia significa
menores em face da rotina vai fazer sem
casa e terá sol e praia na rua anos eu
falava que ela mesma
no entanto está em condições diferentes
na noite duas pessoas que estão vivendo
na mesma casa pensar em aspectos mais
concretos não só de palavras e sempre
difícil produzir gás está em algumas
avenidas 2 a 1
as irmãs vamos fazer outra né depois
pensamos em coisas como uma vaga como
palavra sua irmã espanhol quer dizer
sonho e sono usam a mesma obra mas sim
para duas coisas que são tintas já está
próxima de conquistar a nossa época não
é português
nós temos como lavar sono fica gostoso
estão diferentes línguas é elas são
esquerdas poderosas de solo para contato
comigo não só para o estado estar a
dormir não só a condição de uma noção
muito clara a opção espanhola faz tudo
sozinho dizer a sua equipa de sonho e
pressionando mas temos mais longe da
zona problemática das línguas
não quero pensar só em nós
essa seria outra palavra nós temos uma
coisa que continue se antes um filho
dele
embora também tenha uma palavra aqui
para o formato claro está em fase de
extinção do número 4 no escuro com nosso
século escolas diferentes
rosa e vai reunir são dois todos nós
ambos podem ser efectuadas ao soldado
estavam todas as palavras são é difícil
não é impossível mas é difícil isso
acontece com todas as palavras e com
todas as estradas e deixou os mais ricos
já em la paz iniciaram hoje o programa é
um dos livros mais funcional que elas
estão em constante mudança de geração no
uruguai
o esforço é falarmos a língua já
conseguiu algumas diferenças aqui eu li
fung depois certeza que todo novo e usar
a língua obrigatória a meninada falar
nossa língua seria complicado num
português não podia ter feito na fita
que a obra não tem qualquer a rima da
obra
uma palavra chama outra uma seqüência a
equipe leva a que a obra não pudesse
inscrita em qualquer outra língua que
tem por isso no entanto pois desde que
ele seja trazido para partilhar fazê lo
em nome do espólio ou seja a obra
convida se inscrito em mais línguas por
ser importada para outras línguas todas
eu quero dizer com isso é que deve ser a
língua subinha acreditar numa anos de
casa terá humanos que cassa inicial e é
por isso uma riqueza não só pra ter um
nos outros esperar mas por todas as
culturas e com um celular vai terminar
um desafio que eu acho que tanto eu como
profissional mas nunca num qualquer
língua estrangeira que conheçam e dentro
da silva sérgio faz um esforço e olhar
para o futuro e austrália calculados e
todo mundo gosta de vir à nossa
disposição e se precisar dar explicações
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]